when you buy a company what is the first
three months six months are you hands-on
with that is it
do you have an operating partner who
does that how do you guys make sure that
you and you buy an asset you don't a
destabilize it and be you actually start
to grow it which is I assume why you
bought it in the first place yeah so so
our philosophy there's a lot of private
equity firms out there that have these
like you know 30-day 90 day 120 day
plans right we don't do that what we try
to do is is take a humble attitude
towards it and say look we we we know
some things we have some talents but
what we want to learn and and and come
alongside them they're the experts
they've been doing it for a long time so
there's a team of 16 of us so so it's
not certainly I don't get the impression
this is just me
there's people far talented more
talented than I am on staff and there we
have a dual hook in structured post
close so our financial team hooks into
their financial team and creates
feedback loops and then we have a we
calls portfolio partner they're kind of
a Board of Directors in a box that is
overseeing kind of the executive
leadership helping make very high-level
decisions I mean these are autonomous
operating units I mean so there's these
are these are not we're not injecting
these people into the companies to run
them but they're in touch with the
leadership teams all the time doing you
know a variety different types of calls
and meetings throughout the year how
many companies are there there's nine
that you guys own that got it
so that seems manageable yeah I mean
it's so for every kind of three to five
companies we we acquire we got a higher
one high-level financial person in one
portfolio partner and that's kind of
their their grouping of companies that
they're kind of running so we're almost
creating like a fractal if you want to
think about it that way down into the
organization so that it scales as
certain linearly in that way
[Music]